is from mit who's also like a organizer
of the whole uh of the whole semester uh
who actually wins for the
most exciting title of the workshop so
take it on
thank you all right thanks thank you
everybody thanks for coming uh so i'm
gonna uh
i'm gonna be starting this question what
makes a good fisherman
and uh this is a joint work with uh
yes one's
terrapin and jerry uh from uc berkeley
andrew elias uh who's my student at mit
and
uh manolisa batakis who's a postdoc at
uc berkeley and was a student of mine at
mit also this is very recent work if you
you know are interested in the details
you can find them here in this tiny url
the paper will be published in the next
few days
uh so since i posted this
uh
uh so uh since i published this title uh
for the workshop uh there was some
twitter discussion about what makes a
good fisherman
so gautam kamath said i bet you have to
understand the poisson distribution
uh to which clement cannon
answered a very deep net
to which rohan sukumaran said or
attention is all you need so keep the
discussion going
but uh
so
here's a statistical approach to
understand the answer to the question
so you know how do we figure out what
makes a good fisherman well we collect
data
so we collect data x j y j
where x j are the features of some
individual height weight speed training
etc
and yj is the daily catch of that
individual day
and you know having collected this data
and being genko about our statistical
uh
approach to understanding the world
we fit a model to our data okay so that
model could be a complex model from some
class or
just linear regression like the linear
model
and then we look at the features
the coefficients normally and understand
what features are important for phishing
so this is great except
uh it's missing data from all those
unrealized fishermen like me
so i mean i was trying fishing when i
was a kid i wasn't that good at it so i
i stopped doing it
so the statistician collecting data
didn't get my data
and i presume didn't get
the data from a lot of people in the
audience
excuse me
what is the noise from the fisherman
yeah you have a
gaussian noise or
you know
but
whatever
this is not the point
um so the point is that uh when you
collected your data you didn't get all
the data that you should have collected
because this have been pre-selected by
decision makers okay so to be more
precise
and in fact that goes back to
work of roy in the 50s
who in fact used to say just you know
the exact same example he was thinking
about a village
where uh people may be either fishermen
or hunters
and uh
[Music]
his mental model was the following that
every person has some features
and they try
hunting
all right
uh sorry i'm gonna still use gaussian
noise
okay
sometimes you'll be you're written by
the animal right so
uh
troy's hunting okay
they get uh
you know they realize that their ability
in hunting is something
try fishing
they realize their ability in fishing is
something else
and well they go with whatever they're
good at okay this is what we do so we
try a bunch of things which is what we
are you know best of
second individual in that village tried
hunting and fishing this guy was a
better fisherman
so they chose to do fishing
and so on and so forth
so all the village decided what they do
now
if you're going to collect the data on
on fishermen you're only going to see
these points
if you collect the data on hunters
you're only going to see those points
and if you try to fit a linear model in
these two different sets of data points
you get these two lines
which of course are the wrong lines so
the correct lines are those
those two
right how do you know on all the data
had you collected all the data you would
have found the right lines
but because uh those the data was
filtered by decision makers
uh
you didn't collect a representative data
set and your model is wrong
that is the point of the
of the title in the talk
so okay so let's write down a model
so your phishing income is uh
uh
let's say some
linear function of your features plus
some
shock independent of everything
your hunting income
you know would be again a linear
function of your features with a
different coefficient vector plus some
shock
zero mean uh independent of everything
and what you do is you select
you know whatever gives you the best
income okay so you
you choose a profession that is gives
you the maximum income between these two
and you become the profession that gives
you the maximum of the two
so the observations that we collect
only contain
for every person
what's their income
and what profession they do
right
we don't collect counter functions of
what their income would have been had
they done some other job
so this is called cell selection
our goal is to estimate the models
and do as well as if we had data
for each
all the data all the even counterfactual
data from its profession separately
so so this uh type of self-selection
bias is very pervasive let me let me
show some other examples of it
first of all i mean of course you know
i'm talking about fishermen and hunters
but of course you can imagine different
professions trying to train our
algorithmic hiring software based on
data that we collected from different
professions well guess what the data we
collected are very biased
because they do not collect the
unrealized uh
unrealized
abilities of people who you know ended
up doing other professions
when we want to train you know our you
know uc berkeley software that
guides students about their majors again
if we just focus separately on different
departments if we feed a model on the ma
in the math department
and separately fit a model in the in
data from the music department
uh our models are going to be biased in
the same way and so on so forth okay so
you can you can imagine
this is quite pervasive
because you know many times
uh
there's some filtering that happens
because of people making decisions in
what data it gets to be observed
let me give some other examples of
machine learning
imitation learning okay and i'm going to
talk about imitation learning in this
example
in the setting of linear contextual
so in linear contextual bandits in every
on every day
you observe some context some vector
you're supposed to choose some arm
and in the linear setting
you assume that
the payoff that you get
for if you pull arm i t
is a linear function of the features of
the context plus some noise
right so that's
linear context abundance and you can
generalize of course to have other
classes there again that's not the point
uh so in the imitation learning uh
setting you want to learn a good policy
not by interacting with the arms
yourself
but by observing an expert who is doing
the right thing okay so you are a
trained you know
a doctor in training
you're right so you um
uh you you just you know like you just
observe a a
experienced doctor
patients come to the office the doctor
says okay let's do treatment i.t for
that patient and then another patient
comes and so forth
so you think that the expert chooses the
best okay so the expert uh sees the
context that you see but maybe the
expert also sees some other unobservable
things that you don't see this is the
eta t parts
the expert does the best thing okay
you're observing the expert
in the sequence of rounds choosing
what medicine to give to different uh
patients
so in the end of the horizon what you
have collected is a a data set
that has
which is a sequence of context
which arm the experienced doctor pulled
and how well that patient did after that
arm was pulled
and you want to learn
uh the arms you want to learn the arms
because you know if you learn the arts
and you become a good doctor you know
what arms to
pull in the future yes
maybe i'm going further
but in the first exam with the fishermen
and uh
yeah so
you get two straight lines but that was
wrong
in my in my opinion with the following
sense okay here let's say that you have
the fisherman and here you do not see
any fishermen so the fishermen are
certainly here so you do not know
somehow you have five information that
you get given that the people
in higher kilos
they have a
yes so you can try to exploit that info
but again the point of that's okay so i
guess the question is
uh for those uh non-realized fishermen
i'm pretty sure they're pretty bad at
fishing right so you see me i'm not a
fisherman you say okay doesn't know how
to fish
yeah yeah so uh why don't you throw that
information into the picture you could i
guess the point of the picture was just
doing rls like we used to like feeding a
model is a bad idea now you can try to
use that information we will see the
talk how to use it
uh but that you know
you have to use it yeah yeah
all right so that's example number two
example number two selective reporting
i'm just gonna do some examples okay
just to to show uh the
uh the virus settings where this arises
so selective reporting of sap scores
okay so i'm gonna spice it up a little
bit
so uh
you know a student with features x
uh takes two tests two subject tests
subject a subject b
based on their features how good they
are in different things they get some
score according to some complex model
for the two uh subjects and then their
question is okay like what subject
should i report when i apply for college
should i
give my score for a mu score for b or
both or whatever
so let's say they're trying to decide
between whether to report
subject a or subject b
well what should they base this decision
on
you know they look at statistics from
colleges right and uh
you know um
they know that
you know if they report uh score sa
for subject a
this would be the probability of being
accepted to college
if they report score b
uh
for subject b
this is the probability so what they're
going to do is they're going to report
whichever of the two given the realized
scores for the two subjects they're
going to submit whichever one of them
maximizes that probability
which you know presumably is a
increasing function of
the score they submit for that subject
so they're gonna do some more complex
rules that's the point of the slide so
they're gonna they're gonna
choose which subject to report based on
the arg marks of the probability that
they get accepted if the submit does
score for that subject versus the other
one okay so whichever one is better and
the score they're going to submit is
that one
and again you know like you're sitting
at the admissions office at uc berkeley
and you're like okay like people
submitted some submitted score a sums up
this score b
uh let's try to learn
uh
you know counterfactual things
fit those models we cannot do it if
you're not careful about it if you
cannot be naive about it that's the
point the point is you cannot be naive
about it
right you cannot just take all
uh
uh all students submitting score a and
fitted model on those and those who
submitted for subject p and treat them
all on those you have to
mix it up
in a careful way
all right
from a different part of economics
and this is a slightly
slightly different example so so far
what i've done through my examples you
know like i had two professions here
you know i had k treatments over here
i had non-linear and you know like
you know you know different selector
functions uh here
so for my next example i'm going to do
something a bit different and in fact a
bit harder
and that goes back to uh
what is called market disequilibrium
started in economics uh
where you want to study you know parts
of the market that are not in
equilibrium okay so what does that mean
here's an
example so suppose that for houses with
features x
the supply
in the market is you know some linear
function of the features
and for
the houses with features x the demand is
another line
of the future another linear function of
the features
so you know in a in a in a market
equilibrium supply demand should be
equal okay but in a market this
equilibrium that's not necessarily the
case
so if the supply is harder than the
demand the demand controls how many
houses are transacted and vice versa
so the houses transacted are now the
minimum of the supply and
okay so one changes
compared to before is that i had some
maxes before now there's a win but more
importantly
you don't get to observe which
side of the market is tight you see how
many houses with different features got
transacted but you don't know what's the
limiting factor is the demander is the
supply
in this case all you see is uh features
of houses and how many of the houses
with those features transacted
but you don't get to see which side is
tight in a market disequilibrium
again you want to figure out uh
what's going on
under the sheets okay
uh all right
and i think that's my last example
that's a non-parametric setting okay so
again i gave a bunch of examples of
different ingredients
just to uh convey the generality of the
thing so this is an example uh a
nonparametric example
and this is about estimating auctions
uh it's again a classical topic in
econometrics
so in an auction uh and you know i'm
gonna study auctions uh
repeated auctions
involving the same populations of agents
and i'm going to assume that the values
are independent in every round
so what is called the ipv independent
private value model
so uh i have a repeated uh auction
involving the same populations of
bidders
in every round each bidder draws a
sample from their uh type distribute
that underlying value distribution for
the item that i'm selling
based on some strategic
thinking
they submit a bid to my auction
now this bid is processed by the rules
of the auction and then out comes a
winner and what price they're paying
um
yeah and this is what i'm writing here
so under some so people sample values
under some beige nas equilibrium they
submit their bids
and
you know the rules of the auction
determine what happens and what you get
to see is the winner and the price they
pay out every round
in the first price auction the winner is
the maximum of the bids and the value
the price that they pay is the maximum
of the bids that are submitted
in the second price auction the winner
is the maximum
bid and
price to pay is the second max bit
submitted
so
again this is an example of selection
because there is some data born
some process decides what to do with
them to submit bids some other process
decides
which of them to reveal to you again yet
to see a very partial
view of the underlying data
and what decides what data you see is
some strategic thinking by the bidders
and also some optimization that happens
at the auction house
uh in this example we want to learn the
values from
both so you may want to learn just a bit
distributions or both have been
submissions and evaluate solutions and
and what i'm going to talk about you
want to do that in a non-parametric way
which is
uh in fact it's another problem with
very simple options
okay so to just summarize what i've
talked about so far
many times we have agents
who are fed with data
they do some thinking
and outcomes some
aspect of the data that we get to
observe
in some other cases uh
we have a lot of agents that are fed
data
each of them decides what to do and the
data and how to interact with other
bidders and out of the whole process
comes
a partial observation of the data that
was born in the beginning
so self-selection okay
if i were to give a
definition is a situation where the
observed data
is not all the underlying data
uh of interest for you know building
some model or whatever
but it's the output of some strategic
process that has operated on the data on
all the data and self has sub-selected
some of the data
so this is self selection
uh and uh
you know i've given you a lot of
examples already suffice it to say there
are there's a ton of applications uh in
in
the literature of uh self-selection for
all sorts of different uh
uh topics participation in the labor
force uh retirement decisions
returns education something that you
know us academics like tenure choice and
the demand for housing
uh
you know auctions and so on so forth
okay
uh here's a textbook that
discussed a lot of those obligations
and on the theory side which is the
focus of this arc
broadly speaking we
there are asymptotic
results or identification results but
in many cases there are not even
identification results in other cases
there are no efficient estimation
algorithms and uh
uh this is uh
a very open-ended question okay uh
very fertile for research and you know a
my main goal here is to advertise the
existence of these types of problems of
learning with bias that comes from
decision making that happens in the
in the background
and uh i'm just gonna give you some
results uh in this vein uh some recent
results with my collaborators
but again it's a fertile ground for uh
you guys to contribute and i think it
has a big societal uh value
because as i was alluding to with the
examples in the beginning of my talk
a lot of the
a lot of times if you don't pay
attention you're going to get biased
models leading to biased decisions
right
cool so
this is the intro
and let's try to do some
uh
uh
a deeper dive into a specific setting
uh so i'm gonna uh for most of the talk
i'm gonna study linear models
and i'm gonna start in linear models in
two cases one where you observe the
index
where the maximization takes place and
another like in the in this equilibrium
in the market this equilibrium example
where you do not observe that
so i'll i'll first discuss uh let's see
so what is the general model that i'm
going to be discussing so there are some
underlying uh vectors w1 to double k
these are the ground truth weights and
there is some selection function the
selection function takes a vector of k
things and outputs the
winner not the winner is not the maximum
or whatever it's like some selection
function that says for this vector
values i prefer index
i from 13k
and here's how the data generation
process
takes place given these
fundamentals
so uh here's the so the data factor is
the following so you sample a feature
vector from some underlying distribution
example features of individuals
um
for every i i in this index is uh one
for k for every possible
profession let's think about professions
uh based on the features and the
underlying w vector uh uh there is some
uh skill for that individual decided for
that particular profession
skill level
and uh
the selection function takes us is fed
all these
you know
possible skills for that individual and
says okay you are going to be that okay
so it's alexa it's a lecta an index from
one through k out of the
k possible professions okay so again k
professions
many individuals each individual samples
a feature vector
in the background okay understands how
well they would be for each of the
different professions
and based on some rule maybe the maximum
maybe the minimum maybe something else
the select what profession to follow
and you get to see
either the features of the individual
what profession they follow and how good
they are at it
and that's called the known index
setting
or you get to only observe uh
it
they try they try their hand in a bunch
of things they see what it is that's
it is not noise it's it's like some
something that you don't observe so
right so yeah so they try their hand at
different professions and they go with
whatever they're good at right yeah
question so the left-hand side is when
you know who the catchments are
right
yeah so here you observe
uh pictures of a person what profession
they do and their income here you only
see their features and their income but
you don't see how they got that income
uh it's uh interesting
for the noise it is completely i it is
completely iii so
there's not going to be any causal uh
structure
compound there's nothing
correct
this is zero main independent everything
so let's compare to two settings that
are maybe more familiar that we're
familiar with okay again this is my
setting of cell selection
a well-studied setting is called
mixtures of linear regressions
the setting is very similar
except
what profession you follow
does not depend on you know
having tried your hand at different
professions it's just a random
uh it's just a random mixture over like
like each individual randomly decides to
do
uh a profession
that's called mixture of linear
regressions
it's very it's a classical problem as
well and has received a recent attention
so in comparison to that uh setting
where you know the pi's
some no typically you you want to
identify them but but even if you know
them it's an interesting question and
non-trivial
uh in comparison with the setting i'm
starting though i want to point out the
following right so like
uh in the mixer setting
if
the index was revealed
it becomes a trivial problem so you can
just do or less for different
professions
because there's no
causal mechanism that look like there's
no uh
you know like there's no the what you do
does not depend on you know how good you
are of it so you can just separate the
like if you knew the indices or you
could guess them or cluster their points
or whatever uh you could uh just do
olas's for every profession
over here even if i show you the
profession of somebody
like who's a fisherman who's a hunter
you cannot actually it's not as trivial
it's not trivial to
estimate the models
[Music]
s is known
yeah
but but uh i'm gonna get to that it's
interesting to consider i mean as i was
saying it's a very fertile ground
most of the problems are unsolved and
so there are some interesting questions
where
which profession you follow
is depends on the function of your
features as well so there's a different
linear model deciding that so but yeah
for the model i'm i'm starting here you
we assume s is known
right so that's one first type of
comparison and i guess underlying this
is that over here
the choice of what i star you see is
exogenous it's just a random
randomly sampled
over here it's endogenous it depends on
the skills
and this is the the source of the issue
all right
again this is my setting
and um so now so i'm going to make an
extra assumption okay strong assumption
i'm going to assume that this is
gaussian
uh this is with the same uh
covariance for every
profession and it's known
okay so we're not going to study
settings we want to this is unknown so
we know it and it's fixed across
professions
and we want to estimate the w's this is
we know s
we know uh
sigma sigma has a nice parametric uh
distribution
we want to learn the w's so this is the
problem i would be studying for most of
the time today
very many times
i hope the setting is clear
yeah so
all right so um
so what do we have so here's a result
that we have
under some mild assumptions i'm going to
discuss
with n observations we can construct uh
estimates of the underlying coefficient
vectors
uh so that the maximum l2 error
scales like
[Music]
log n over n
um
now okay so this order hides some
dependence on underlying some
parameters of the problem and i'm going
to get to that a little bit after i
state the assumptions themselves
and the running time of the algorithm is
also polynomial and everything
okay so what are the assumptions that we
place
uh
we assume so these are the standard
assumptions you make so some of the
standard assumptions you tend to make in
linear regression itself okay so you
assume the future vectors and the weight
vectors the coefficient vectors are
bounded in l2
you assume that you have uh you know the
empirical covariance is thick enough in
all directions
right
those are the standard assumptions that
you make in linear regression let's
uh
um
yeah
no reason to dwell into them so much um
but yeah so upper bound of the witcher
vector c
on the weights b
and you have this uh
thickness in all directions of the
covariance of the of the fee of the
combines of the future vectors although
this relies really very strongly on the
independence of the arrows right
hand there's a better fisherman and the
other way around
obviously breakdown
it's so good because it relies very
strongly on the assumption of
independent errors
um i mean there's an identifiability to
begin with but then also the estimation
everything i'm talking about holds under
i did
like independent noise yeah
i mean
yeah if they're not if the eaters are
dependent on each other and then
it's kind of what most economics has
been kind of troubled with right
selection
sure uh
so
it does not mean uh zero means reflects
unobserved confounders
in economic rates and it is a big
challenge
uh over here
the confounding comes from the fact that
i don't see all of the data so there's
still there's still like uh
uh they're still confounding here right
so
uh
you know things are realizing
so you're still not in
a nice uh
space
like i suggested all the identification
result would be that if they put
fishermen exactly the same as the good
hunters that's something you can never
reject without the parametric structure
right
if they're good fishermen are exactly
the same people as the good hunters
that's a model that's always kind of
consistent with the data
it's not for the structure
i i think it's an interesting question
to study situations where you have
correlated noise models we don't we have
not studied that but it's it's a next
step yeah
uh all i'm pointing out is that there's
still
issues with that identification here
okay
because of this selection process so
these are two orthogonal directions that
you can that you can work with right
like eat like
the correlation between us captures the
fact that there are some unobserved
confounders
okay so here i'm assuming you observe
everything that you need to observe
right so the rest is you know
zero b
but there is this selection bias so the
selection bias
is here very present
yeah so first two assumptions i'm pretty
far standard what is the meaning of the
last one i understand that it is a
covariance matrix there but what's this
thing to issue
uh let me not put too much into this but
roughly speaking uh if you're not taking
no directions then you cannot like some
coefficients uh of the w vectors are
indistinguishable all right like
like for example if you're zero i know
in some directions you cannot tell us
that right
but these are standards
um
the uh uh second assumption what i'm
gonna make and that's necessary
is that
there isn't a profession out there that
is not chosen okay so like it's some
profession that is chosen you know
zero probability or very close to zero
probability i mean for zero probability
you're not gonna have any data for the
profession so you won't be able to
identify the coefficient vector
uh but but you know and as the
probability tends to zero you have to
pay for that in the same complexity
so
uh what the way we're gonna parameterize
the problem is to assume that
uh every profession is selected with uh
uh you know at least some alpha over k
probability for some alpha and we'll
parameterize our results with this alpha
k is the number of professions we'll
assume each of them is chosen
probability at least alpha k
so you want to band this picture so
where you never become a hunter
and
you want to be in a situation that you
tend to see you know all professions in
your data
last assumption has to be go it has to
do with the selector function
so in many examples i was talking about
the maximum maximum
selector means you know
you output
[Music]
y1 or y2 depending on which one is
bigger
we you know but we can handle more
complex selector functions you don't
have to go with the maximum
so ultimately what we need is that
the slices
the horizontal and the vertical in any
direction the slices
are convex
okay so
uh
for every profession and for every uh
possible skills at that profession
uh
you want that
if you were to cut
you know fix at some value and then look
at
which values of y2 uh give one as the
winner you want that set to be convex
so you don't want to be in this
situation where like this slice here is
non-convex right so
uh i guess maybe this slice
depending on the colors yeah
uh
okay so maximum function that we have
been using uh
you know the you know uh
you know having some fixed monotone
functions per profession and choosing
the arc marks of uh you know that
function the skill all of these conform
to this setting
all right so now to state the result
under the discussed assumptions
yeah we get uh errors that uh
you know defend polynomial and these
parameters like the variance of the
noise and inverse that the bound of the
weight vectors and the features the
minimum probability and the number of
professions and logged in over and the
running that's well known
yeah
the data generation
yeah the data is generated uh yeah dude
let me get to that again
yeah so i guess so for this result you
don't need the distributional assumption
on x actually you can get away with just
a a worst case design
as long as it satisfies the properties
that i mentioned
yeah so you don't need parameter
distributional assumptions in fact
this is an expectation
so in your results you say that this
lesson is i expect that yeah
the expectation is good yeah over there
yeah
if
the assumptions
yes
uh
i mean i guess for someone unless
there's not this
you shouldn't be you shouldn't be paying
i mean uh you should be paying for one
of these two
you have to pay for these two yeah these
two are not there
you have to pay for those
uh and you know you don't need to pay
for one of those like uh you don't need
to pay for large packages for small
markets
yeah yeah so i was gonna have do you
have intuition for
why
excuse me
um
i might be missing a square here
yeah i might be missing a square there
yeah
all right so what is the approach um
well so um
so you start writing a likelihood
function okay so what is this lucky
problem is a bit weird let me try to
parse it
okay so you average over all the
observations the end observations that
you saw this mixed bag of
people professions
and their incomes
um
for a fixed skill for a fixed feature
vector
you pretend
you have infinitely many resamplings of
that individual for now on the average
those so you for a fixed
feature vector of that individual you
look at the population
the population of
income and profession samples
for that
you know feature vector
according to the true model which you
don't have but you think about this
function
and
then you look at the log likelihood at
a guess of the at the current guess of
the vectors w1 to wk
the log lacquer of
you know the the the log probability of
uh given this feature vector having
observed that income and that
profession so you think about this
function okay of course you don't have
infinitely many samples from the true
model
but you can still think about this
function
so your goal is to show that this
function is strongly concave this is
actually what we're going to show
it has a unique maximum of the two
parameters
so that it can be computed uh
uh
efficiently
even though we do not have infinitely
many samples
and uh yeah
these are the goals all right so so yeah
we want to do stochastic convex
optimization correct
that's what we do
what looks like to look at this function
for a sec i mean
i'm not sure you are in the mood for uh
this but uh
okay this is the expectation according
to conditioning of the future vector
again you know this expectation stays
the same i'm just
reminding you because this is hard to
make what it is it's just some
calculation involving normal random
variables
uh so
conditioning of the stitch vector
to observe this profession with this
income it has to be that
this noise vector uh you know satisfies
this equation
and also that this quantity dominates
all other professions this is what it is
for the max
correct
for this for for
for you to observe uh
uh
oh you're right
okay yes so you have to do okay
so i'm doing the proof for the max
selector you're right
you can do it for any selector uh
[Music]
maybe this is correct
i think okay if you skip this line this
is correct for the general selector
function
so yeah so you have to sample
this value for this profession
that is winning
and
the other ones must be rejected
so you have to integrate you know like
uh you have to integrate a gaussian
distribution over some set which is the
slice that gives you i star as the
winner so this is general this is for
the max selector sorry about the
confusion
but okay it's not important how it looks
like okay but um
let me tell you what is commonly taking
place and where the why why it looks
like that so if i take the gradient of
this function
so no matter the details okay so if i
take the gradient of the function
it's the difference of two expectations
it's an expectation with respect to the
two parameters of some quantity let's
not write it down it's going to be
complex
my news
and this is
illegal says something about the
structure of the problem a mixed
expectation that i'm writing here
where you sample a point according to
the true model
conditioning of the features
and then you sample the the remainder
from the model at which w at which you
are currently in your gradient descent
procedure
so uh this having this mixed expectation
is very common
uh when you try to learn models with
latent variables
so in my scenario here what are the
latent variables the relative variables
are are all those unrealized professions
these are the y minus i stars
of the world this is me as a fisherman
me as a musician etc etc
these are all the latent values that i
could have gotten
that you don't get to observe so
we have a model with latent variables
whenever you try to do likelihood
in models with latent variables if you
look at the gradient
you have this uh
mixed expectation
appearing and also an expectation
respecting the true model this is quite
common
and you know like models with latent
variables are actually pretty hard to
solve
um
yeah because you know another way
another thing that commonly happens in
in models with latin well we have this
log integral so this log integral is not
good news for for for maximum molecular
estimation
okay
log integral is not good news uh
integral of log is good news but log of
inter isn't so and variational inference
of basically tries to exchange the two
but
in our case surprisingly uh the function
is actually concave so despite this log
integral and this double expectation
these structures that you know
uh arises in latent
variable models it is uh concave
now
like
coming back to my analysis remark from
earlier okay so like here we have a
population quantity of course we don't
have infinity samples from the true
model however
for a particular feature vector xj we
have seen one sample from the real world
we have seen this you know whatever got
realized for that particular individual
so with this one sample and plugging in
that sample into this expression we can
get an unbiased estimate of this term
uh now for this mixed term
you know we do have one sample from this
model
which is the true model and for whatever
is inside we can try to simulate a
sample
from uh
this distribution because you know that
is a distribution parameters w that we
know we can just try to simulate and get
an unbiased estimate of the whole
gradient
this would be the approach
let's table that observation for now
so uh
you know the extra things that we show
which i promised earlier is that the
optimum happens of the two parameters
and that
and that's a unique option because we
can show the function is strongly
concave
now coming back to this observation that
we can get unbiased estimates
if you have unbiased estimates for the
gradient you can try to do stochastic
gradient descent
and the world would be nice if you could
do that right so start somewhere in your
constraint set
and you know like
uh get an unbiased estimate of the
gradient to follow that
if that ever takes you outside of the
set project down to the constraint set
and keep going
and you know because the optimal occurs
at the right point you get it okay so
that life would be nice if that was we
could do that
the challenge
though that arises
is that uh sampling from from this uh uh
distribution is actually
not
uh
clear how to do
uh so uh uh because
you know like um
this profession
and this income for this individual was
realized under the true parameters
and that might be a very unlikely uh
scenario
for the parameters w where we try to
sample from this conditional uh
distribution giving i star as the winner
with income y i star
so because gradient descent will wonder
firing you know and our constraint said
uh you know just doing rejection
sampling uh to sample from this
conditional and normal or distribution
is not actually
uh
it might take exponential time
and what we do in the paper is we do uh
langevan dynamics too to to to solve
this issue
uh
and uh let me uh
basically the whole thing boils down to
the following situation
you need a sample from some gaussian
center that's some view
[Music]
uh constrained on a conditional on
sunset l
and that l may have a very low
probability under your gaussian that you
want to sample
what you know it has big probability
under some other gaussian with mean new
star so you have a set l that has high
reasonably high probability under new
star
but
um you and me star are some distance
away from each other
which may make your set have
exponentially small probability under
new so you cannot just do rejection
sampling
uh from new to get a a sample in in that
condition
lying in the set
so uh what we show is you can do uh
lanzavan dynamics to actually
do that in polynomial time okay so this
is what we use uh details i guess uh
don't matter at this late time
some directions for this part of the
talk
it'd be nice to have
more complex
noise variance models
[Music]
potentially correlated
among you know
different professions
more complex selection mechanisms there
was a question earlier by mean i believe
where
the selection itself is not known but
you also have to estimate it
and of course doing more uh complex uh
models estimating more complex yes so
maybe you have priorities i'm not sure
let's say that i
um sample nonzero probability of all the
progressions
probably
right but my selection is that never
choose
uh
among all these professions
it never chooses the first
so it takes the max out of the other
ones correct
you never get
an enough estimator of these points
correct
so how can does it
yeah so one of my assumptions was that
under w star
you sampled each profession with decent
probability right
excuse me i'm sampling with decent
probability all professions my selection
processes uh no but
it was it was it was about
this requirement it was about i mean
there's no suffering of professionals
you try your hand in every profession
and then the selected function tells you
which one to choose like that selector
function always uh
disregards one of the professions
there's no hope
what i assumed is that the selector uh
with respect to all the probability of
the system selects this professional um
yes so
my question here uh uh so of course yes
with lantern you can uh you can get a
polynomial uh polynomial depends on the
dimension
but uh you cannot
i know
all right so
interesting directions all around some
of them already raised
by questions and stuff so let me try to
wrap up
so we have some results where we are no
need exciting okay so i'm reminding you
that in the arnold in that setting you
don't get you get to see the features of
attention on their profession but not
how they make that money
uh and you know already compared to
mixtures where kind of like if you saw
the profession that would be trivial
uh uh and sort of like uh the word it's
exogenous which profession they do over
here i have endogenate in non-trivial
even when i i do see the profession so
um
and the point here is that uh
the concavity of the log likelihood is
out of the picture so you don't have a
low concave likelihood in this
latent variable model
and in fact identifiability is not even
obvious in this setting
so in our work we resolve
some of the issues uh here so we
under uh some more
stronger assumptions right so like
assuming uh a distribution on the x's
uh assuming uh and doing only the max
selector so under under these two
assumptions
uh we can extend we can show
identifiability
and we can get
efficient algorithms
for certain
things
let me summarize here so we can get
identifiability uh uh
for every k
uh for every k uh we can uh efficiently
identify the span of the
of the feature of the coefficient
vectors
and for k equals 2 we can get everything
to be efficient for general k we don't
know the answer to that yet okay
so this is basically what i wanted to
talk about
uh coming back to
my
uh this slide here
um in many
cases and i hope i showed you
several examples in the beginning right
so
the data that you get to observe to do
your statistical analysis has been
filtered
through a process involving decisions
uh uh made by people and other strategic
phenomena and you cannot just blindly
trust that data to do your statistical
analysis
and
you know
i showed you some results for efficient
estimation when you observe the index uh
and some identification results uh
i didn't get which i didn't get to for
unknown index and again the the future
is uh opened with
several interesting directions to push
you thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you for sticks so we're opening
the floor for uh questions
yeah so i wanted to
go back to the sigma question because i
found it interesting that you paid one
over a
um because you know you would imagine
that less noise would be helpful
is the issue that
um
so you know is this because you're
trying to learn the weights themselves
so you
i guess it boils down to uh
you know yeah so the question is about
sigma uh i don't know where that slide
is
but i guess what guy did you have you
have a guarantee that uh
the set has decent mass under this new
star
and you have some constraint on the
distance between you and your star
as the sigma gets
smaller uh
you know it gets even harder for like
things that are far away to
uh right so there is something like
right so it becomes rare to to get that
set but does the problem get
like if you just tried to learn a map
from x to the profession
maybe you could do that if sigma is very
yes i mean it's a limiting i mean this
one like this uh sigma one over sigma is
a feature of our approach it's a
but it is not necessary i mean often in
linear regression having small c like in
illinois regressions having small signal
is good for you right right
yeah as we discussed earlier in the time
yeah
we don't it's a construct you know we
we're using langervan for this uh
specific thing and we need to play this
one over sigma
so one over sigma is because of black
otherwise
so you may have covered this and perhaps
i missed it i was wondering if it's
possible to do some kind of survey of
the population like in some settings
maybe you know how good the average
person is at fishing or at
hunting maybe you just have some surveys
or something is that something to bypass
the whole complexity or like to help
with assessing the
what the
information
filter yeah i mean if you right if you
have if you have access to this kind of
functionals first of all you can break
it up by profession and problem solved
but maybe like there is an intermediate
model where i don't know maybe you have
some
noisier
noisier understanding of the unrealized
samples and right like you don't see for
the samples that you get you don't see
exactly the scores for those ones you
just know something about it yeah so
these are all fertile this is all
fertile ground for for
investigation yeah
have you thought about bandits or other
kinds of partial feedback in this
setting so this is one kind of
partial feedback or like partial data
i feel like bandits this kind of
selection happens after like you select
and then you observe the y's whereas
here you first get wise and then you get
you select
so
i'm not sure if you thought about that
um i mean
you know
i mean
you know i guess in bandits you have an
adve i mean you you select i mean
it
related to bandits one interesting
direction is doing soft max type of
selection uh
right so you like imagine you're
observing a doctor who's doing uh xp3 or
whatever
uh
and uh so the selection uh that they're
using is uh
not just max this is the software
version of max
maybe it's you know randomized as well
uh so it's it's interesting to consider
things like that there
now to model the adversary i haven't
thought about it from this lens i feel
like
i mean the adversary has
i mean yeah i haven't thought about it
from this perspective yeah
so i i have a question regarding the
known versus unknown in the index
setting so it seems that the
[Music]
uh that means being being closed
together it's beneficial in the
known in the setting but might be not
beneficial in the
unknown because you're gonna be able to
distinguish
between the professions right so
is there any extra assumptions we need
to do
um
you're right uh
we
like for example like you know like i
mean this is effectively under the
it's a it's a profession selected uh
i mean you uh
yeah so so but that that is swept under
some assumption of this form that
you get to see every profession
with this approval but but yeah i mean
yeah so it will i mean
this is yeah some yeah some collinearity
has to be avoided in that some i think
some extra you have to place
it specifically for that but yeah i
guess my question was especially for the
linear model yeah yeah yeah
yeah so you
uh you
we throw in an extra assumption for the
you know together with this you know its
profession's chosen at least with
fraction over k we also want to avoid
some uh yeah collinearities and stuff
i mean you know like i mean
philosophically you you could think like
you know
two w's are the same like this is the
same profession you're different i mean
it depends on exactly what you want to
achieve but no
thanks this is very interesting so
related to the
like one over sigma question yeah so
what
goes wrong if sigma is zero
what was wrong with
solve
sigma
problem
using another approach
oh uh you mean like in the not in the
approach but in the general setting yeah
i think like if sigma is zero in the
general setting this would be an easy
case right because you see part of the
line like this part of the line like
that everything is linear you learn it
so no problem yeah but for this approach
it gets difficult correct because again
this is a technical uh issue that arises
with landsave right so like i don't know
the limit as sigma goes to zero but i
know that sigma equals zero it's a
trivial problem so you know as i'm
getting there uh you know expect it
shouldn't be a hard problem but it just
it's like you know this approach
presumably if sigma is too small you're
not you should not use this
correct
right
you can do maybe other things like
we didn't really focus so much on that
to be honest
just a very very quick question uh your
complexity result results
for projecting
which is the intersection of l with a
pole because l should be complex yes
okay so
that's a separate
issues that the money are important
right
correct
[Music]
i think that's
thank
it